- [Voiceover] I once saw
a high school teacher lead
a simple, powerful
exercise to teach his class
about privilege and social mobility.
He started by giving each
student a scrap piece of paper
and asked them to crumple it up.
Then he moved the recycling
bin to the front of the room.
He said, "The game is simple.
"You all represent the
country's population,
"and everyone in the country
has a chance to become
"wealthy and move into the upper class.
"To move into the upper
class, all you must do
"is throw your wadded-up
paper into the bin
"while sitting in your seat."
The students in the back
of the room immediately
piped up, saying, "This is unfair."
They could see the rows of
students in front of them
had a much better chance.
Everyone took their
shots and, as expected,
most of the students in the
front made it, but not all,
and only a few students in
the back of the room made it.
He concluded by saying,
"The closer you were
"to the recycling bin,
the better your odds.
"This is what privilege looks like.
"Did you notice how the
only ones who complained
"about fairness were in
the back of the room?
"By contrast, people in front
of the room were less likely
"to be aware of the privilege
they were born into.
"All they can see is 10 feet
between them and their goal.
"Your job as students who
are receiving an education
"is to be aware of your privilege,
"and use this particular
privilege called education
"to do your best to achieve
great things, all the while
"advocating for those
in the rows behind you."